>> Greg: ANOTHER NEW VIDEO OF
A MOB DRENCHING NEW YORK'S
FINEST.
GROUP ARMED WITH PAILS OF WATER
TARGETING TO FEMALE OFFICERS.
THIS INCIDENT COMING DAYS AFTER
EARLIER WATER AMBUSHES IN THE
CITY.
IT OFFERS A LESSON IN HUMAN
NATURE.
IF OTHER PEOPLE SAY THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITH CRIMES, THAN OTHERS
WILL DO IT TOO.
THE LACK OF RESPONSE BY THE
OFFICERS BEFORE OFFERED PASSIVE
ENCOURAGEMENT.
IT'S ONLY WATER.
TRUE.
WHAT'S NEXT?
WHO KNOWS.
WE KNOW WHY THE COPS DON'T
RESPOND.
THESE ARE THE GUARDIANS OF A
LIBERAL ENCLAVE SO OTHER THAN
THE HARDWORKING TAXPAYERS WHO
WOULD SUPPORT THEM, NOT THE
LEADERS THEY PROTECT.
ANY ARREST WOULD DROP PROTESTS
OF EXCESSIVE FORCE AND AL
SHARPTON WOULD BE OUT WITH A
SIGN BEFORE YOU COULD SAY.
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK IS MORE
FRIGHTENED OF MEAN TWEETS AND
CRIME.
WE KNOW WHERE CITY HALL WILL
STAND IN THE RIGHT UNDER THEIR
DESKS.
THE MAYOR EMBARKING ON AN
ALREADY ABSURD PRESIDENTIAL RUN
WILL USE HIS SON ONCE AGAIN AS
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THE NYPD
RACIALLY PROFILED MINORITIES,
EVEN THOUGH THE FORCE IS LARGELY
MADE UP OF MINORITIES.
SO THIS COULD GET WORSE, AS
PRISONS CLOSE IN DETENTION
SUSPECTS ARE RATING TRAILERS
LIMITED FOR MANY IN 2020.
IT'S A LESSON LEARNED IN MAJOR
CITIES, ACHIEVEMENTS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OVER DECADES BY
COMPETENT HUMANS AND PRINCIPLED
POLITICIANS CAN QUICKLY ERODE
ONCE ELECTED IS IN CHARGE.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE YOUR FUTURE?
TRY DOWNTOWN L.A.
WATCH WHERE YOU STEP.
THE POLICE ARE IN A TIGHT SPOT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY
SHOULD BE FIRED IF THEY DON'T
RESPOND.
BUT IF YOU DO YOUR JOB, YOU RISK
BECOMING A PUBLIC SPECTACLE.
IF A MOB FORMS AROUND YOU AND
YOU END UP HAVING TO TEASE
SOMEBODY, YOU'RE THE BAD GUY.
>> Martha: ABSOLUTELY.
THEY ARE IN AN UNTENABLE
POSITION.
YOU LOOK AT THE SPECTRUM OF
HUMAN BEHAVIOR, THIS IS WHERE
LAWLESSNESS AND SUBHEADING.
PLACES IN THE WORLD WHERE THE
POLICE DON'T LIKE TO GO
IN BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
WELCOME AND IF THEY DO SOMETHING
THEY MAY GET ATTACKED.
THAT'S THE SEED WE ARE SEEING IN
THESE MOMENTS.
AS YOU SAID, IT'S SO EASY TO
TRIP OVER TO THE OTHER SIDE.
PETE THESE PEOPLE GET UP EVERY
MORNING AND RISK THEIR LIVES
EVERYDAY TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW WHO'S GOING TO BE LESS
SAFE BECAUSE OF INCIDENTS LIKE
THIS?
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THAT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WHO WANTS TO
BE A POLICE OFFICER TODAY?
IT'S A VERY, VERY TOUGH JOB.
I GIVE THEM AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF CREDIT.
THESE ARE APPALLING SCENES FOR
ALL AMERICANS.
>> Greg: JESSICA, SHOULDN'T
MAYOR de BLASIO JUST CALL IT A
DAY, COME BACK AND TRY TO RUN
HIS CITY?
>> Jessica: YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THAT
ONE.
>> Jesse:
PRESIDENT de BLASIO?
>> Jessica: PLEASE USE HIS
FORMAL TITLE, KING OF THE
BLACKOUT.
>> Greg: NICE.
THAT IS TRUMPIAN.
>> Jessica: DON'T SAY THAT.
HE SHOULD COME HOME AND RUN THE
CITY.
I THINK THERE ARE 12 TO 15
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD GO BACK TO
THEIR VERY IMPORTANT JOBS AND
LEAD US ELECT SOMEONE WHO CAN
BEAT DONALD TRUMP IN 2020.
THIS IS TERRIBLE TO SEE.
I GREW UP IN NEW YORK CITY.
COPS AROUND ALL THE TIME, ALWAYS
HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM AND THEY DO US A GREAT
SERVICE.
I WENT AND LOOKED AT THE DATA.
CONFIDENCE THE POLICES HOVERING
WHERE IT HAS BEEN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS BUT RESPECT FOR THE POLICE
IS ON AN UPWARD TICK AND THEY
CREDITED WITH THE PROTECTIVE
MEASURES BEING IMPLEMENTED, MORE
BODY CAMERAS, EXTRA SCRUTINY OF
THE DEPARTMENT THAT HAS TO
CONTINUE.
OBVIOUSLY TAKING THIS TO THEM
MORE NATIONAL CONVERSATION HERE,
I THINK THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
THINGS LIKE THE POLICE OFFICER
WHO PUT ERIC GARNER IN A CHOKE
HOLD AND HE WALKS.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT DON'T
GET PEOPLE CONFIDENCE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OF
THE POLICE FORCE THAT THEN LEADS
TO NOT NECESSARILY THE WATER
SOCCER STUFF BUT LACK OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE FOREST.
>> Jesse: I WOULD AGREE THAT
THE RESPECT IS THE CORNERSTONE
OF GOOD POLICE WORK BUT IF YOU
LET SOMEONE PUBLICLY
DISRESPECTED LIKE THAT AND YOU
DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT, IT'S
GOING TO MAKE YOUR JOB OR
DANGERS IN THE STREETS MORE
DANGEROUS.
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE ACTED.
YOU KNOW WHEN MEN, INSTEAD OF
PUNCHING ANOTHER GUY, THEY
SLAPPED HIM IN THE FACE.
IT'S LIKE THE MOST HUMILIATING
THING YOU CAN DO TO SOMEONE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS LIKE.
IT'S ALMOST MORE DISRESPECTFUL
TO THROW WATER ON A COP THAT IT
IS TO RESIST ARREST.
THAT'S WHAT THESE GUYS WANT.
THEY WANT TO BE SEEN IN THE
STREETS AS BEING DISRESPECTFUL
BECAUSE FOR SOME REASON, THEY
THINK IT HELPS THEIR STREAK
CRIED, AND SO WHAT IF THEY GET
ARRESTED?
IT'S LIKE A BAD GIOVANNA.
THEY COME OUT AND THEY CAN TELL
EVERYBODY THEY'VE BECOME
LEGENDS.
THAT'S HOW STUPID THIS WHOLE
THING IS AND THIS DOES HAVE ROOT
CAUSES.
THEY HAVE COLIN KAEPERNICK,
EVERYONE'S HERO, WEARING SOCKS
THAT HAD POLICE AS PIGS.
THEY HAD BILL de BLASIO SAYING
HIS OWN SON SHOULD BE CAREFUL
WHEN HE'S AROUND POLICE
OFFICERS.
THEN YOU HAVE BLACK LIVES MATTER
CHANTING FRY 'EM UP LIKE BACON,
CNN WANT TO HOLD JIHAD AGAINST
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
SECOND OBAMA TERM THAT WASN'T
VERY SMART.
>> Martha: NEW YORK CITY
POLICE OFFICERS TURNED THEIR
BACK ON BILL de BLASIO WHEN HE
WALKED BY THEM.
>> Kennedy: IT'S NOT FAIR TO
BLAME THESE THINGS ON
COLIN KAEPERNICK.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT BLAMING IT
ON HIM BUT IT DOES HAVE A ROOT
CAUSE SOMEWHERE.
>> Greg: IMAGINE THAT THOSE
ARE TWO WOMEN SURROUNDED BY A
MAJORITY OF MEN, IF THEY WEREN'T
POLICE OFFICERS, THIS WOULD BE
ACTUALLY ASSAULT.
YES.
IT IS AN ASSAULT.
BUT SOMEHOW IT'S NOT MAKING THE
NEWS.
>> Kennedy: THE MAYOR HAS TO
COME OUT.
FORCEFULLY AND SAY HOW THE
POLICE ARE GOING TO RESPOND AND
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND THERE'S A
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD IN THIS
COUNTRY ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
THE PEOPLE ON THE STREET WITH
BUCKETS DOUSING COPS, THEY ARE
NOT THE ONES WHO ARE LEADING THE
CHARGE AND THEY ACTUALLY DO THE
ENTIRE MOVEMENT OF GREAT
DISSERVICE.
IT'S INCREDIBLY UNFORTUNATE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO BEEN IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT TO SEE.
THE WORRY IS, WHAT DOES THIS
ESCALATE TO?
TO YOUR POINT, I JUST HIT A
WALKING TOUR OF SKID ROW IN
LOS ANGELES.
ABSOLUTELY PUTRID, DISGUSTING,
SAD.
THE WAY THE CITY GOVERNMENT IS
FORCING HUMAN BEINGS TO LIVE
THIS WAY AND IN PORTLAND,
MEMBERS OF ANTIFA THROWING QUICK
DRY CEMENT ON PEOPLE,